nous continuons à évoquer à l'actualité
locale sur ce plateau du 7-8 les
représentantes de l'union musicale à 100
syrienne qui présenteront le 1er mai
leur festival de majorettes sont restés
sur ce plateau on va parler d'un autre
sujet le produire fermier est ce que
vous êtes amatrice de ses produits
fermiers justement acheter directement
auprès des producteurs ils ont plus
voilà alors vous avez potentiellement
deux clientes face à vous on va parler
du pari fermier qui a vu le jour il ya
peu plus de 20 ans da paris depuis
l'opération s'est exportée en banlieue
aujourd'hui ces quatre salons à peu près
parents se disent une dizaine de salons
par an dizaines de manifestations par an
effectivement tout au long de l'année
tout au long de l'année c'est pas juste
sur rue sur une petite période du
printemps vraiment tout au long de
l'année à c'est toute l'année et ce
justement des rendez vous hongrois par
les périodes d'hiver et en période d'été
où les gens sont ou renfermé où
justement un peu partie bon une fois par
mois à peu près se donnent rendez vous
aux gens et la prochaine étape donc
rambouillet 3 au 5 mai alors on parle de
pari fermier c'est quoi le pari
justement quel pari vous vous êtes lancé
c'est surtout les agriculteurs puisque
ce sont des manifestations
d'agriculteurs en direct qui se sont
lancé des paris donc soit des paris
d'indépendance un praticien producteurs
fermiers quelqu'un qui est qui est
indépendant qui veut faire les choses
par lui même sans être sous la coupe ou
de la distribution ou d'autres c'est un
pari de créativité possible puisque ces
gens là font également la transformation
de leurs matières donc créé des recettes
c'est un gain également un pari de
savoir faire il faut savoir que les
paris fermiers sont organisées par les
producteurs eux-mêmes dont juge et
partie il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire non
plus organisateur professionnel qui est
là de façon mercantile
c'est un pari de l'engagement enfin
l'engagement sur une charte les chartes
nationales d'engagement des producteurs
fermiers qui stipule ce qui est
réellement producteurs fermiers donc des
producteurs fermiers quelqu'un qui qui
produit ou qui élève ses animaux qui les
transforme et c'est une appellation
officielle sans label officie c'est par
un label officiel parce que c'est assez
compliqué du fait de la diversité des
régions
montagnes plaines etc et
des activités pas du miel comme on fait
du froid voir comment on fait du fromage
mais néanmoins sa a été créée en 98 donc
cette charte est tout
nos producteurs il sembla sur adhérents
et c'est très contrôlé c'est contrôlé de
façon très interne par nous
effectivement des très sélectif sur la
qualité de producteur fermier de nos
participants donc absolument aucun
intermédiaire il ya pas d'artisans si
bon soit-il il n'y a pas d'intermédiaire
commercial de commercial n'était pas de
revendeurs et le producteur agriculteurs
en activité qui travaillent à l'année
sur son exploitation est réellement
derrière derrière son stand et ses
produits et vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir réussi ses différents paris
justement oui oui tout à fait et attend
à entendre les producteurs c'est
vraiment quelque chose à laquelle ils
tiennent et qu'ils arrivent à réaliser
c'est un message qui font réellement
passé à l'occasion de manifestations et
le public vient en général nombreux sur
rambouillet combien de personnes vivent
à rambouillet ça marche très bien donc
c'est à peu près cent dix producteurs ça
tenait à chaque fois on monte un petit
peu plus et c'est donc selon la météo
selon diverses contingences c'est en
général douze mille visiteurs avec super
captifs avec les différents scandales
sanitaires vous attendez encore plus de
succès peut-être justement ce cétacé
facilitant et vous en parle est ce que
justement ça l'est les producteurs aussi
que vous avez en contact vous en parlez
vous disent aujourd'hui on est plus
sollicité les affaires reprennent marche
mieux en tout cas les gens viennent nous
voir directement il ya à la fois un
effet crise pour savoir quand même que
le produit le produit fermier n'est pas
un produit de base non plus donc c'est
un produit élaboré qui était fait dans
les règles donc il ya son juste prix et
il ya également ces
affaires mais qui sont pas récentes 1
l'histoire du cheval sait pas c'est que
la suite de pas mal de choses qui a
effectivement facilité et quand on
parlait de paris tout à l'heure il faut
également se lancer dans le paris de la
responsabilité ou le producteur est
complètement responsable du produit
qu'ils présentent donc si on n'est pas
content et ça n'arrive jamais si on
n'est pas content on sait vers qui vont
peut se retourner c'est à dire c'est la
personne qui vous l'a vendu c'est la
personne qui a donc transformé les
produits c'est donc la personne qui l'a
qu'il a produite quels sont les produits
que l'on va trouver à rambouillet bas
plein
tout ce qu'on peut trouver dans une
ferme on le trouve à paris fermier est
réellement enfin ce lieu bergerie
nationale qui est déjà magnifique
est un excellent écrin pour revaloriser
tout ce qu'on peut y trouver et ça va tu
dis je dirais du sanglier d'élevage au
lapin
alors ça on a même en nouveau un
producteur de vers 10h05 l'île de ré
donc de lapins de toutes les viandes
porc chevron
brebis découvrir les fromages couvre les
producteurs aussi les métiers
véritablement qu'ils font justement posé
la question et chenni culteurs parce que
vous connaissez les échines sculpteur
là bas justement ce sont les éleveurs
d'oursins tour sans fin et on a d'autres
castanéiculteurs
châtaignier rien est des plus classiques
et en pisciculteurs paludiers aussi
alors le kiwi culteurs existe et le
trufficulteur mots comme son nom
l'indiqué aussi pour les pour les les
trucs les producteurs aussi sont de plus
en plus nombreux à vous sollicité pour
adhérer à cette charte véritablement et
pour venir aussi à la rencontre
directement des consommateurs il
n'adhère pas la charte près de nous
c'est à dire s'ils sont dans les clous
ils sont forcément adhérant à la charte
est ici une quelque part en participant
chez nous on nous sommes une oreille une
organisation associative donc pour être
adhérent chez nous il faut avoir signé
cette charte ça fait partie de nos
statuts et effectivement ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à vouloir
participer chez nous malheureusement
certaines fois on met un peu le holà
parce que
on veut pas qu'ils aient trop de fromage
ou trop de trop de vin ou trop de
de cannes un grain pour ne pas
déséquilibrer manifestations mais on y
arrive très bien selon de manifestations
et surtout à rambouillet ou où ça énorme
diversité
super intéressante puis ce sera
l'occasion d'une grande fête aussi à de
nombreuses animations qui sont prévues
même sur le site de la bergerie comme
chaque année vous pourrez faire le tour
de toutes ces régions françaises de tous
ces produits qui seront proposés du 3 au
5 mai à rambouillet jeu justement on va
revoir la fiche pour que bien je vous
redonne la date 3 au 5 mai pari fermier
pour découvrir donc s'est produit plus
de 100 producteurs fermiers des quatre
coins de la france